[Music]
this is star talk sports edition
this one titled taking a hit
more on that in a couple of minutes i'm
neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist let me introduce my
co-host chuck nice jack hey neil what's
happening all right
hanging in there chuck my professional
comedian co-host who loves sports though
never did it professionally well thanks
for pointing that part out okay
for the professional side of sports
we've got
gary o'reilly former soccer pro current
sports commentator and we are lucky and
privileged to have him for star talk
sports edition gary how you feeling i'm
good my friend and the privilege is mine
and thank you now you're always cooking
up shows with clever titles and
and you're digging people out of places
that i didn't even know they were hiding
and so what do you have in store for us
today
um
all right we are going to meet someone
who is not just a cannabis user but
we're back on marijuana you can't let
the subject go can't apparently not okay
someone who has now gone into the cbd
business
okay and who happens to have been a
world-class
athlete
with a unique and fascinating story
which we are going to share with our
audience today uh then we're going to
open it up to our regular expert in
these matters the pot doc herself dr
stacy gruber love me some stacy gruber
we don't haven't get enough of her yeah
we yeah offline chuck was saying we
should we should start a whole cannabis
spin-off star talk read edition start
talking weed edition
it'd be weedly wouldn't it
yeah um okay so the backstory to our
guest today
drafted by major league baseball but
never
swung a bat in anger
he is however a heisman trophy winner
now just remember heisman trophy right
just for a minute put that to the back
of your mind and he's a former nfl
running back one of the best there was
in the business um but he pretty much
took up a permanent residence on the
nfl's naughty step for a while
uh eric myron is
someone you'll know formerly as ricky
williams and he's a man who
did things his own way
uh as a player he failed multiple drug
tests was fined considerable
amounts of money retired and then
returned to the nfl where he proved once
again just how talented he really was he
is a qualified yoga instructor
a subject of an espn 30 for 30
documentary currently if i'm not
mistaken a student at emperor college
santa monica on a masters program
studying
traditional oriental medicine
and the force behind the heisman brand
which supplies a range of cbd
products heisman i see what he did
yeah spell spelt in two different ways
i followed you there there you
welcome eric eric myron welcome to star
talk
thanks for having me it's great to have
you
yeah so let me ask when when you were an
active player on cannabis were you
thinking
of its the the breadth of its medical
value to you at the time or you just
just wanted to smoke some pot
well i think how much thinking went in
at the time i think it's it's it's
somewhere it's somewhere in the middle
you know because we always frame our
experiences
based on our understanding and
you know i hadn't i wasn't privy to the
fact that there were conversations going
on that people were talking about the
medicinal benefits my experience and why
i kept coming back to it was because i
was getting some benefit from it but the
the training was that there was no
benefit so it was it took me i had to
have the
experience for myself well you mean the
prevailing wisdom of the day was that
there's no benefit yet you have direct
conflicting evidence to that in your own
use
exactly yes wow
that's pretty cool man you were ahead of
your time
yeah yeah you're you're you're a athlete
who was way ahead of your time
i wouldn't say i was ahead of my time it
just was more that i valued feeling good
more than i value money yeah that's
that's way ahead of your time bro
i'm not sure if you've seen the state of
all professional sports nowadays but
yeah that's way ahead of your time
as an athlete yes yeah eric let's let's
do the obvious thing here you were
formerly known as ricky williams you are
now eric myron and if i don't ask this
question right now check is going to
bounce up and down like a four-year-old
child for the rest of this podcast so
what was your thinking in terms of
changing direction there
well you know the simple way to put it
is is when when a woman gets married and
takes on her husband's name
you know it's it's normal but the
reality is that's the that's just a
convention it's it's a tradition
um
and so i thought about the tradition and
i said
i don't get it you know for me i never
understood like what why does everyone
take the male's name especially the kid
because when when the kid is born we
always know who the mother is but we
don't always know who the father is so
it just makes sense for the for the
feminine line to to extend and so i got
married and i said hey that makes sense
to me and so i just i said how do i take
your name
and the added benefit was being a famous
football player most people know ricky
williams as a football player and it's
more of like people's idea of what a
football player is supposed to be and
sometimes that felt kind of like cramped
for me
and so i've realized the the side effect
of changing my name is there's just more
more freedom right that i get to step
outside of you know the old identity so
i feel like i outgrew ricky williams and
you know got married had a kid and said
hey this makes sense you get high and
you're woke
this is this is that's the whole point
to me that's the whole point
i was gonna say i was not expecting such
a a thought-provoking progressive story
behind the name change and uh i'm
thoroughly disappointed uh i
thought thought you were running from
the law or something damn
it turns out you're just a super
conscientious dude and a deep thinker
it's like uh okay if he's running for
the law he ain't very good at it because
he's on our show right now
he's front lit right
you read retired in 2004 from the
dolphins right yes um
and
if i'm wrong correct me please you went
off to california to study ancient
holistic medicine um
what was this itch that you were
looking to scratch at this point in your
journey because not many people walk
away from the dolphins and retire yeah
career
honestly i was looking for a job that
felt good to me
it's like i said earlier really i've
realized
you know it took me a while especially
as a football player to value feeling
good as a football player i always was
in pain always was in physical pain
emotional pain word who was judging me
it just was it was it just wasn't me
and so when i walked away from football
i started traveling around the world and
and it was interesting i started meeting
people who didn't even know what
american football was and so i started
to get a different reflection of who i
was and it was i liked what i liked what
i saw and i realized that i was a
sensitive person who really enjoyed
making other people feel better so
you know another part of it was as i
like came back down to reality i
realized i've been a football player my
whole life i don't really know how to do
anything else and so i the itch was i
need to develop some kind of skill so i
can be of use and then i i put them
together i like making other people feel
better i need to develop a skill and so
i looked for some training in how to
make people feel better
uh it's called stand-up comedy
thank you much
yeah i was gonna say
you know not for me but for us
for other comedians otherwise it's
stand-up disaster right
were there other botanicals eric that
you
gravitated towards other than cannabis
or was it just the cannabis that you
were using to
manage balance yourself at that time
you know it was it was
what i what i stepped into was really
an understanding of uh of a medical
system that uses herbs so you know
growing up in in america like i thought
medicine is you just take pills
you know and the idea is something that
hurts it doesn't work and then you do
something about it and this different
model was really about understanding who
the person is in providing
qualities
this is what i learned in ayurveda
providing qualities that keep that
person in balance okay meaning if
someone is is as really is really slow
metabolism okay right there's certain
foods that are that they're going to be
able to digest and there's certain foods
that are going to give them difficulty
and so you use herbs that are lighter
okay or someone is is uh sweats a lot or
they retain a lot of water okay you use
herbs that that create balance
um and so as i started to learn about
that at the same time i was also
learning about myself
and so
my understanding of botanicals is that
certain botanicals
people or objects right foods things are
more attractive to me you know at
certain times and a big part of ayurveda
which really intrigued me
was
when i was traveling around the world
after i retired someone gave me a book
on ayurveda and i opened the book and
the first chapter was about living in
accordance with the seasons
okay
and and i remember back when i was in
preschool i remember i remember i was
three years old sitting in preschool and
we were we were learning about the
seasons okay this rudimentary
information okay and but growing
becoming a an adult i forgot all about
the seasons you know for me it was just
football season in the off season
yeah do you know what i'm with that i
understand that completely yeah so but
but as i was before i retired okay i was
really wrestling internally with how can
i invest so much of everything i am into
this one thing
and then all of a sudden i'm starting to
have other interests it doesn't make
sense to me and someone i was
as i was wrestling with this someone
mentioned the idea of seasons to me and
that was the only thing that helped it
make sense is that is that one season
naturally flows into the next and i was
realizing that i was moving out of a
season of being a football player and to
be into being something else and so when
i read that this book about living in
accordance with the seasons it just
spoke to me
really it really spoke to me and just
this world view of things are constantly
changing and if we want to stay healthy
or stay in some kind of balance we have
to be able to to adapt and move with
those changes okay you're describing how
sensitive you are how how much you care
about other all this does not fit
anybody's stereotype of a football
player and
like we said in in your intro you kind
of did it your way but that was at a
cost to you
is there did you figure what kind of
sort of financial
cost it was for you to be yourself and
thereby get suspended get fined whatever
um did you is was there a calculation
you did and you'd say to yourself
i value being me more than i value
getting paid to do what everybody else
wants me to do
yeah yeah because you know when i when i
was getting paid a whole lot
right it didn't make me happy if it did
i trust me
i would have i would have still been
doing it right
and and it was more that the thing i was
doing to get the money was so against
who i actually was that that was the
that price and i don't think there's
there's any amount of money
any amount of money though i would do
something that i know is not me that's
why i stopped being an assassin
it's uh
oh chuck
yeah man it was i gotta tell you man i
grew a conscience and it really i just
couldn't do it anymore it was tough yeah
so you get it anyway
i loved that eric is the only guy that
liked that joke he was like
he was like
neil and gary are like who the hell what
eric was like dude that was a funny joke
oh well all right anyway eric what's
your feeling on the current and we're in
2022 right now the current nfl stance on
players failing tests because
they don't get suspended anymore they
just get a dent in the wallet so how do
you feel from your situation here
looking back at that
you know i feel satisfaction
you know that that there's not going to
be anyone that has to go through the
experience that i went through anymore
and i like to think that you know me not
only me taking a stand but the way i've
lived my life
as a cannabis user you know i think that
that's what i find has made the biggest
difference in people when they meet me
and they have a conversation with me and
any kind of ideas they have about what
cannabis does to people it starts to
melt starts to melt away so i'd like to
think that something about my story
helped move the conversation so that
these changes are starting to occur
last summer and the the build-up to the
olympics in tokyo shikari richardson
goes through a traumatic experience
smokes a joint gets bang banned
and now bring it forward to today we
have brittany greiner locked up in a
russian jail for allegedly possessing
marijuana vape cartridges
how do you feel about those two
incidents right now
so i i'm not i'm not trying to say that
they are
uh
connected in what i'm about to say but i
am trying to say that they are connected
so one of the things about the history
of of
of cannabis and at least in this country
is it's been a tool
used against people of color
absolutely right and so because of that
there's a there's a there's a stigma
around it you know it's like if you
think of a of an african-american using
cannabis you get an image
right if you think of a caucasian using
cannabis right you get another image and
they're they're different and part of
the the history is is part of the the
cracking down against cannabis was one
way to oppress you know uh minority
cultures but when the the soldiers came
back from vietnam and they brought you
know uh love for cannabis back with them
it kind of spread into the colleges and
universities and you started having
college kids starting to consume
cannabis and then the laws became kind
of weird right because we can't
right we can't persecute the the white
college kids they're just experimenting
right so it was complex and i think to a
certain extent we've we've outgrown a
lot of that but some of it is is still
is still hanging around you know and so
again i'm not saying it's directly
connected but i think it's interesting
that the two people you brought up okay
are african-americans
so
but the the i think one of the things
though that these situations has brought
to the surface
is people are having conversations about
it and i'm and i've seen at least with
cannabis when people that we don't
expect take a public stance about
cannabis things will start moving much
faster because the stigma starts to to
fall and i remember back in 2004 when i
was going through everything with the
nfl
no one or no one said anything
positively no one put their neck on the
line or shared how they actually felt
about cannabis because it was still too
early but with shikari you saw a lot of
people step forward and make a stance
and because of that we're starting to
see a lot of the the rules change
well i don't know anyone who runs faster
after smoking a joint or do anything
right
with enhanced right
it's interesting
and what's what another thing that's
interesting is and this is just in
general about especially athletes um
using cannabis is more it's more about
punishing them and it's less about
asking them right what are you using it
for how is it about your home
yeah because the thing about shikari is
is she came out and it said she lost her
mother and cannabis was helping her deal
with what was going on that's a mental
health issue right you know and one of
the big and i'm proud of the nfl for
this the nfl players uh players union
they they stay in the negotiations in
the past you know using the the drug
testing has kind of been a carrot in the
negotiation process okay right and the
players wanted the money more but the
players have now said this is
this is non-negotiable for us cannabis
is a is a wellness issue
it's a it's not a it's not a substance
abuse issue i think we're seeing that in
in the general society as a whole
where and partly because i don't know if
we're going to get to your cbd business
but i think a big uh component of that
is partly because of the you know the
usage of cbd oil and cbd products
because people are seeing um
a health benefit that they're deriving
from that usage uh
but they're also making the association
that oh wait a minute this is
this is a derivative this is from you
know this it's the same thing but it
doesn't have a thc right right well
we're gonna get closer into that subject
in the next segment and don't forget in
our third segment we're going back to
the pot doc to
tie a bow on all this and get a sense of
what the medical research on the
frontier shows us so we will be right
back with eric meyer on star talk sports
edition
we're back star talk sports edition with
our special guest eric myron who is a
former nfl pro heisman trophy winter
winner uh turned sort of uh new age
uh
student blippi i'm a car i'm a i'm gonna
call you a fellow blippi yep that's a
black hippie yeah
that's a black hippie he's a he's a
fellow blippi i tell people all the time
that i'm a blippi i just don't dress
like one and i don't let him up i don't
let my uh my curls go long but you know
i'm still a blippi i'm i'm gonna call
you because i knew about
black nerds i'm also a blurby
so eric you went into business and
you've got the brand heisman
h-i-g-h-s
m-a-n heisman uh
really brilliant name there we see what
you did there
and this is to market products of
different derivatives from the marijuana
plant and so what what led you to go
into business doing this i guess to a
certain extent it is it is marketing the
the derivatives the
the secondary metabolites of the
cannabis uh sativa plant but but really
it's you know i created this more to
accentuate my platform
so
just to clarify one thing in 2018 i
launched a cbd company called real
wellness and i was combining
cannabinoids with traditional uh herbal
formulas created medicine that company
is still going uh last year last
september i launched heisman which is in
the thc space
and it's specifically to talk about
heisman it's a way better name than real
wellness i just thought i'd put it out
there yeah thank you thank you yeah we
we're evolving right we're real
yeah well the idea behind real wellness
and it's somewhat related to heisman is
that
is that for me a large part of my
wellness
has includes cannabis but but the the
typical thinking at least at the point
was that cannabis was not about wellness
yeah right so this theme is gonna this
theme is gonna keep going all right
and and so with with heisman yeah i did
win the heisman but also right getting
high has become like a negative thing
where i was reading some book i've read
some books so written in this in the 60s
and the 70s and they talked about being
stoned and being high as a positive
thing yeah you know and so i and that
relate
that that resonated much more with with
me
you know but really the conversation is
when when cannabis became
um useful to me is when i was
dealing with mental health issues
okay and so my definition of mental
health at least the basis of it is when
we say mental we're talking about what's
going on inside
okay inside and the health right is it
it feels good right we feel good and i
wasn't feeling good and a big part is
because i wasn't paying attention to
what was going on on the inside when i
started you split your product into
three groups of pre-game halftime post
game what is what's going on there
so it's a it's a naming convention to to
help people understand um the effects of
cannabis
you know because you know you talked
about uh taking a hit and a big part of
what i want to talk about is what people
do after they take the hit and so
pregame is the idea of it's what in the
the common nomenclature people call
sativa it's more of a of a it's more
mental more stimulating more active okay
uh and then postgame is what people are
tend to how about
you gotta
and
you know really most of what we are
consuming in in the states is
technically a hybrid
yeah it's a hybrid and it's and it's
kind of a mixed effect is a way to
simplify it right and so the idea is
giving people a way to think about the
effects of cannabis again what do they
do after they take a hit
totally uh personal question man
um
how do i get into this
how can i get into the weed biz man
i'm telling you right now man this is
gonna be huge it's already huge but
people have no idea you think the
alcohol industry is big i mean alcohol
is
deleterious all the way down the line it
is straight all the way down the line it
is it is a degradation okay on your body
on your psyche everything this actually
has benefits this is the future of
people being
recreationally relaxed how how do i get
in ricky how do i get it well how would
you like to get in
i don't know man i i'm serious what i
say i don't know but yeah what do you
want to do what do you what would you
like to do in this chuck i thought your
comedy career was going great
man you know something about it hey let
me tell you something
my career ain't going as well as weeds
you can do you can do weed comedy
for real like that's the beautiful thing
about the space is it's a large industry
so whatever your skill set is there's a
there's a place for you a slot a slot
you got to figure out what that slot is
right all right i'm gonna work on that
work on that i'm gonna reach out to you
man all right so but you
you have thoughts and
and
intellectual
ambitions or dream states
that include space
when you're getting high is that correct
did i understand that correctly
yeah
yeah i was i was starting to to explain
that yes that when i when i smoke i'm
i'm thinking about planets and
stars constellations the cosmos
etc yeah really you know to me i feel
like i feel like this is an intuition
that that life seems chaotic but when we
look up there's some kind of order that
could help us make sense of the chaos
ah neil what
no all i can say is i'd look up and
think about the universe
without weed so
if so oh my god so now you know what we
got to do now
now you know you know what we got to do
now
we got to get neal high
[Laughter]
eric we got to smoke some weed with neal
oh i would love that i love love
there's going to be a big audience for
that by the way but let me just say so
so eric there's i mean we have software
now i mean the old days we'd had to
find an ephemeris and look up tables and
times and dates and longitude and
latitude on earth in order to know where
things are and where they were going
where they were going to be when you
were going to be at the telescope and
now it's just all in apps basically yeah
and so the art of finding things in the
night sky is gone
but now you can find many more things
because you're not wasting your time
digging up tables and trying to
calculate things yeah yeah but you know
it's like using an abacus neil it's like
you know it's
yeah you have a calculator and you don't
need it and you have software but you
know there's something about moving
those little beads across that bar that
does something to you mentally that an
app never could
yeah you will never invent an airplane
on an abacus
system there's some stuff that is
forever out of your reach
so eric tell me because i'm a i'm an
academic and i value people's ambitions
uh their curiosity as it takes them into
whole
whole realms of thought and
understanding is the universe just one
of many
branches of thought that stimulate you
i would say it's in a sense it's it's
like the
it's what i use to help understand
everything else
oh so it's like a primary driver in your
life
yes and so my experience actually is is
i'm building an app and so
the reason i was doing the calculations
is because i was and i'm just for my own
personal use i was building an app for
my own personal use and so that's why i
was going through the calculations of
learning how to use
a computer uh in my phone to tell me
where where the planets are on specific
or where where they were on specific
dates
um and it the one thing that i took away
from it that blew my mind was it was the
first time i had to really think about
time
you know
as a construct because as you're trying
to find you know where something was at
a certain time like different people had
different definitions of how they were
counting time and you have to get clear
on that first before you can answer the
second question yeah by the way in time
and space are interlinked so something
that people don't consider but maybe
they should or could is when you launch
something from earth to land on mars
you are launching a moving rocket and a
payload
off of a moving platform
earth
because it's orbiting the sun headed out
into space
to an empty point in space
where mars will be
when you get there
and so the the orbital dynamics of this
are deep i mean it really is as they say
rocket science right and and so but it
connects you to the universe like
nothing else and i'll take any excuse
people give to look up and start
thinking about the universe man we
wasting this conversation i'll be right
back i gotta go get some weeds
got the munchies
so eric well i just have one question
here so cool if i'm if i'm getting this
if i'm getting this right it took a
tremendous amount of confidence
for for people to launch something to
see if they're if their hypotheses
of where the planets are going to be
where we're accurate
well so i confidence is not the right
yes
correct
but that's not the operative thought the
confidence was in the calculations
though yeah well exactly so so
confidence is in the calculations we
have the laws that's why they call laws
of physics they apply here there
yesterday and tomorrow and so now
we calculate with those laws of physics
i get somebody to double check my
calculations case i forgot to carry the
do you know you want to do that you can
triple check it on a computer or vice
versa and once you've done that it's
going to go where you send it unless
some third other phenomena happen you
know when gremlin comes in and grabs it
you know short
you know
minus the possibility that there's
something about the universe you have
yet to discover it's going to go exactly
where you expect it to go that's how and
why science works
that's what it's why there's science at
all but how do you account for that that
variable of something that science
hasn't
found yet yeah it just messes up
yeah
it doesn't we messed up for less wait we
had a mars probe all right mars orbital
surveyor or something and it went to
mars it just blew past mars
it didn't go into orbit we said what
happened what happened and we found out
that the engineers were using english
units and the physicists were using
metric units
and when they calculated the thrust they
used two different units and it was too
much thrust and we lost uh you know what
was it a uh you know
i don't remember what that probe cost
surely in the millions so that was
embarrassing so stuff could happen
even if there are no gremlins is what
i'm saying why are the british getting
blind again because you aren't stuck
so gremlins is that is that that's like
a term that you guys use
[Laughter]
actually there's something called
maxwell's demons which are these things
that make things happen that we know
they happen but we don't have an
understanding of why they happen
and so
maxwell james clark maxwell in the late
19th century
uh and had this concept that mitchell
maxwell's demons and the electron moves
there because there's a demon that makes
it happen he doesn't really think
they're demons but
we don't otherwise have an explanation
well you need a variable right you need
a variable exactly it's just nature
doing it yeah so yeah they're called
maxwell's demons they're fun you can
look them up they're kind of fun to
think about i'm definitely looking at
that that's where i live that's where i
live yeah but don't rely on them to get
stuff done all right you gotta you know
well you can have no you can't rely on
them but you can use their assistance
[Laughter]
that'll be interesting that would be
interesting
walking down the street and a whole pied
piper of maxwell's demons following him
oh man that's i love it that's not
something i want to see so eric let's
come back to heisman you've got three
products right now
are you looking at building this empire
and if so
where
would you see yourself taking it because
how how are you going to hire chuck
first but yeah go on yeah of course
that's a given so i mean how are you
calculating combinations um
compound strengths efficacy
because you know what all of us on this
podcast are all slightly different
yeah so in education
yeah what's how you do education is that
education is huge and so
we're starting with with three skus
we're starting with three products but
really the the purpose of starting with
these three products is to start the
conversation
right you know and there hasn't been
enough open honest conversations about
cannabis how people are using it and
what they're doing after they use it and
so part of this is creating a platform
because you know in the future right
cannabis use is to me is the future
right i think it's going to replace
uh pharmac a lot of pharmaceuticals and
i think it's gonna to a certain extent
replace replace alcohol but part of for
me part of using cannabis is you have to
learn how to function when you're having
this more awareness of your subjective
or internal state and especially for
guys we don't have a lot of practice
and so for me it's really accessing our
internal emotions right yes it's about
building a community of world potheads
that that's what that's really what
heisman is that's really what heisman is
about i love that that's
doing that or doing something that are
just doing something in the world
that you you got to make that your
tagline man it's like heisman building a
community of woke potheads yeah i'm
telling you man
you can't go wrong with that there's the
t-shirt chuck
all right we gotta take a quick break
eric i'm delighted to have you um thanks
for calling in on on this show when we
come back we're gonna bring on dr stacy
gruber the pot dog and this is not her
first rodeo on star talk when star talk
sports edition returns
we're back star talk sports edition
and it's taken a hit we've called it and
we've just come off of two segments
uh with eric meyer former football great
heisman trophy winner
and now someone who's going into the
business
uh marketing selling and marketing
marijuana and its derivatives to help
people and we can't have a show on that
without going to our go-to person on
this very subject dr stacy gruber stacey
welcome back to star talk oh my gosh and
and let me i gotta get i'm gonna i have
to read this because i'll never get it
straight director of the cognitive and
clinical neuro imaging core at mclean
hospital's brain imaging center okay
that's not enough apparently stacy and
associate professor psychiatry harvard
medical school
that's also true and you direct my
marijuana investigations for
neuroscientific discovery i love it and
affectionately known as the pot doc um
you listened in on those first two
segments with eric so what's your
reaction to him as a person to him as a
user to to his life's arc
you know i think he's had an
extraordinary
experience here and i think a lot of us
forget what early days were like
so many people these days talk about
cannabis and cannabis based
exploration as if it's always been this
simple so gary how old is he now
he'll be circa 45
30 45. that's old enough so he so uh so
you're right i stacy he's from another
era
so i think in and yeah people tend to
forget it was only in 1996 that we
re-legalized cannabis for medical
purposes in this country in california
and in 2004
it was a very different day from the day
we are living now right so it was a
really really different road and i think
that he's had some unbelievable
experiences
um and i have no doubt that this has
allowed him to sort of move along this
trajectory where he's taking his own
experiences and his own desire and
moving them forward as a healer you know
i've never i can't believe we've never
asked this or maybe we have and i just
forgot
but there has got to be a great deal of
data from countries where uh cannabis is
legal
and in other words yeah
what what is what what are the uh stats
on
the usage uh addiction uh
crime
is there anything that's notable
i i think that in general we don't pay
enough attention to your point um
to data that comes from other places and
other spaces
we tend to have a fairly um egocentric
view of these things here and the us
history with regard to cannabis as he
touched upon is the candace has a really
storied past and not for great reasons
um it's one of the sort of um darkest
areas in in history in terms of of
substance use misuse mis labeling
perhaps and now finally sort of a
reconceptualization
i'm not sure that we have a great sense
of how those data inform us we're very
busy saying but that's that's their
experience not necessarily ours although
there's a lot of lots of lessons that
could be learned and i think in places
where they have more liberal use we
certainly see different patterns we
don't see the same rates of certain
types of crime we don't see the same
rates of things associated with
substance misuse or or
quote the old uh the old terms just be
dependents right so then some it's sort
of like alcohol think of countries where
alcohol is introduced to individuals
within the sort of family environment at
young ages we don't necessarily see the
same rates of difficulty with alcohol
when those folks
get to quote legal age we just don't
so what about the the stereotype
that people smoke weed often are
demotivated
and he's he seems pretty motivated to do
[ __ ] done what he wants but what what of
that stereotype what could what can what
can you tell us about this i think the a
motivational syndrome data has largely
been um i think questioned at this point
because i think a lot of things factor
into these equations it's not just the
cannabis use it's how much it's how
often it's at what stage in your food
developmental process what else is
happening and also i love to remind
people what's in your we it's not all
created equal it's not one thing
and as he very appropriately alluded to
when he's talking about his pre-game
game and post-game regiments and these
chemo bars that he's really referring to
or strains if he will varieties of
cannabis sativa l the name of the plant
the reason he's pointing these out is
because different chemo bars or
cultivars have different constituents
that give them different
effects
i think i don't remember if it was you
chuck probably because chuck's very
astute in this particular area um not
everybody's created equally either we
all have different you know each of us
on this podcast everybody was gary we
all process things differently different
metabolism different genetic profile
different experience and that's going to
affect things too but you know it's the
constituents in cannabis it's not just
thc and cbd it's those terpenes
terpenoids the essential oils in
cannabis that give it its characteristic
scent and hope flavor profile are often
related to things like couch lock oh man
i can't get up i have to sit here and
just chill that's you know very often
related to some of the the terpenes that
are there not just but and but they're
people who might react to it more
along that path like you're saying then
along another because there's some
highly productive people among them carl
sagan who was a
famously
uh famous pot user often and a lot and
no one ever accused him of not being
productive that is you know going to be
my go-to example for you given this
particular round here at star top
carl sagan who's very close friend was
lester grinsberg who was one of the
greatest cannabis researchers of all
time from harvard running school um
close friends and carl sagan apparently
used to say the lesser you just don't
understand it and lester made it his
mission because of his friendship to
understand it better it actually became
a saving grace for his own son who was
battling cancer and who was having
terrible difficulty eating after these
treatments had changed his life
ultimately changed his full trajectory
but that's right nobody would accuse
carl's sake of not getting a lot of
stuff though right so wow i had no idea
that carl sagan smoked weed i i this is
the first i'm ever hearing of it but now
it might explain maybe he wasn't seeing
billions of stars he was only seeing
millions and
then he exaggerated it well no
[Laughter]
but i think at the time or recently uh
his widow andrean served on the board of
the of normal the national organization
for the reform of marijuana laws right
oh wow
so so i think they the two of them
together as a creative pair because they
published several books together
co-wrote their first cosmos together
so i think whatever whatever example one
puts forth
of
either demotivation or what any other
negative effects
they have to be counterbalanced with the
examples that are the exact opposite
and therefore you have to ask where do
you land on i'm just repeating what
you're saying stacy we have to ask well
how does it affect you
and maybe you need a different
combination of those derivative
chemicals or none on all or all of them
right
right certainly no shortage of examples
of people who get a whole lot of things
done and who are wildly successful who
embrace the use of cannabis organic
nutrients no question
so stacy
with eric's range and heisman there's
that like say pregame alertness
motivation half time anti-inflammatory
and calming post-game pain relief
relaxation and sleep
with your knowledge research etc
where else
is eric likely to go in terms of
developing products using
the cannabinoid and the
the elements and compounds within i say
let's not uh go there on the air
publicly let's save that information
for a private conversation
that's right i think he was he was
pretty clear i think on the educational
aspects of this right like allowing the
conversations to start and continue to
figure out not only the best
combinations of what i think he was
alluding to which are the individual
constituents and compounds to address
specific ailments or or conditions that
people have but also to get people
talking about it to help ultimately
destigmatize you know there are
differences in people who are using for
different reasons and the stigma that
goes sort of across the board to
everyone
is rather inappropriate at this point
when people acknowledge i'm i'm not
looking to
just you know get high i'm looking to
address these symptoms which may or may
not be his historic either
that's very different and so i
appreciated that part but in terms of
other areas you know i'm not sure what
else he he's not covered i didn't i
didn't give an exhaustive list but i
think for sure something that's
important to him given his own
experiences is mental health and we're
certainly seeing an explosion of work in
this area our hours and and so many
others which is a long time coming just
from my people you are associate
professor of psychiatry at harvard
medical school so when you speak of
mental health you speak of that as a
professional uh in in the field first
and foremost we are psychiatry 100 of
the time we do lots of other things but
one of the things that we're very
invested in is understanding the ways in
which
the the real world experience of
individuals whether they're patients or
have some concern
where there's concern where there's less
concern and how we might be able to
allow people to use what we know
to inform their best practices if you
know just say no doesn't usually work so
now we want to say you know something a
little bit more uh educated that guides
people
um there's a lot to learn in this
particular space
so neil in this in 2022 we've got the
nfl spending a million dollars right as
a grant for studies into the efficacy of
marijuana and its component parts for
pain management and concussion
treatments which goes back to our good
friend marshall
also
you've got wada the world anti-doping
agency conducting again scientific
review this year in 22 to see if it
still makes sense to continue its
international ban on marijuana so i'll
ask dr dr gruber what do you think
they're going to find and how do you
think they're going to bring those
results and thinking forward
in terms of what water will do or and or
with the nff
so i think the the nfl initiative is an
incredibly important one and there's
been lots of interest in this particular
space and the folks who are doing the
work at ucsd are fantastic
uh there's a lot to sort of california
san diego age yes and is a million
dollars a lot of money yeah i'm gonna
say that's kind of cheap for the nfl
yeah given that you know some players
make a million dollars before half time
yeah i i think um i think there's let me
put it this way i think there's so much
work to be done there would never be
something that would be too much let me
put it that way there's a lot to do and
i think it's a very important area to
begin in given what we know about
individuals who sustain head trauma
or traumatic brain injury and how that
looks over time and what we might be
able to do either with regard to
prevention or treatment i think it's
incredibly important i think wada is is
likely to take i would hope a very
holistic view at this point there's been
an awful lot that's happened and wanna
has changed as you pointed out i think
previously they've changed their sort of
um
approach a couple of times so let's see
what happens but i'm hoping that they'll
use a fair amount of data remember there
are substances with similar therapeutics
effect there are similar therapeutic
effects to cannabis and cannabinoids
sedatives anxietics that are not banned
by water
aspirin's not banned ibuprofen is not
banned right
and so when we think about that you know
that's important to keep in mind for
people who are using specifically for
those reasons especially as chuck
alluded to earlier stuff that's not
necessarily
comprised of a lot of thc
where you're really looking at the
non-intoxicating cannabinoids to get at
some of the
inflammation related issues or pain or
sleep whatever you have to consider this
slightly differently i think
and i just checked tom brady's salary he
makes a million dollars by half
half time
wow so you've answered your own
questions
all you've done is aggravate chuck even
more
that's the truth
nothing could be truer chuck the eagles
fan okay what a waste of a million
dollars
so
dr gruber you you introduced i'm gonna
try and steer this back onto the road um
you introduced us to the endocannabinoid
system in the body that's true syllables
for me all right um and as chuck says
he's so distinctly yes right distinctly
captioned it as we're designed to get
high last time that we had you as a
guest
where are we now because this doesn't
sound like ancient research into this
system this sounds like something that's
been happening recently so where are we
and how far along
in terms of what we know about the
endocannabinoid system
so um i think we've we've begun to make
a lot of progress there's a lot of work
in this area and while we may be wired
for weed that's not likely the reason we
have cannabinoid receptors we make our
own hence the term endocannabinoid we
make our own chemicals that bind to our
own endo as an endocrine system as
endothelial right as a yeah it's
endogenous so we have an endogenous
system of chemicals and receptors
throughout the brain and body the other
cannabinoid system every mammal has it i
think there's an awful lot that we've
learned there's more still to go but in
terms of how individual cannabinoids
interact with the endocannabinoid system
that's the interesting thing when we
think of the plant there are over 120
phytocannabinoids things from the plant
that directly interact with our own
endocannabinoid system the ways in which
those things happen is is still being
determined we've just really made a lot
of progress in a couple of more of the
major constituents and there's a lot of
room to to grow here so we have the
receptors
not for
smoking weed although it serves that
purpose we
we feed those our own receptors
so right so think of it as in terms of
opioid receptors do we have opioid
receptors because we're supposed to be
using heroin no we have opioid receptors
because of the ways in which our our
neurotransmitters our brains and bodies
function so in the case of cannabis or
can average really quickly
we have anandamide and two ag these two
chemicals and we have these receptors to
which these things bind and we have
things that break them down break down
these chemicals so that's our own system
it just happens so heroin hijacks our
own system
heroin in terms of opioid receptors mu
and kappa opioid receptors different
different systems but yeah again it sort
of exploits the fact we have these
receptors it's just not necessarily
designed for that they just have to be
effective
it's making use of the receptors but
it's not necessarily what they were
designed for specifically right because
i think they're people who want to
believe they were designed for that and
so therefore it should like and i wasn't
there
at the design table i wasn't there had
you been you would have given advice on
a much better decision something
something i want to ask doctor
by the way that was a
famous all right we didn't get it i know
president at the time of creation i
would have given the good lord advice on
how to do it better so
i attributed a quote to eric that he
said wasn't him but it was something
that indigenous tribes people
thousands of years ago
believed that you needed an altered
state to heal
how would you react to that doctor as
terms of what their thinking was and you
know are they
somewhere they shouldn't be or are they
on the right line or or and i can advert
that and we got to kind of end on this
question but i can invert that and say
what happens
if you heal in a non-altered state
what
what is the benefit if there is one at
all or is it just
you we just want to have it like like
giving birth you're in a whole other
mental state and you forget
that you were ever in the pain you were
as i'm told
and so there's some physiology that that
that promotes that fact
it's you know i think it's a really
interesting question and it's one that i
i think probably depends on what we're
talking about when we're talking about
healing from what
mental versus physical i mean you're all
connected right and so it it goes
without saying that perhaps in some of
these these times um it is very possible
that in order to quote heal you have to
allow yourself the space if you will so
that may be altered from your everyday
you got to give yourself time and space
can you heal without being altered um
sure uh i think the the you know so the
rigid answer is yes of course what do
they mean by that i like to think that
maybe they mean sometimes you have to
have a little bit of a shift in set to
allow yourself to heal most thoroughly
and comprehensively does that mean
stoned not necessarily uh so yeah but it
could also mean that once you come out
of that mental state you don't have easy
memory back into it so that you you your
your life is not burdened by the
memories of pain because they happened
in a different mental state you were in
a different room at the time
or it could be that they were just
getting high and then they found some
benefits after they came down you know
it's like yeah man i can't believe it
every time i get high and you know my
knees used to hurt and now they don't
you know people will say this a lot
they'll say i had to be altered to
experience xyz123 and now i have a
complete shift in my consciousness in my
everyday life that wouldn't have
happened without that that is very
common when we think about things like
hallucinogens ayahuasca and
these people i'm
please again judgment-free zone it's all
good i i don't know uh that's very
possible and i agree yeah when you talk
about ayahuasca it's like it's so the
the resources going into it now one of
which is they're finding that it is um
it's
effective at helping cure and cure
addiction there are people who use it
and they come off of heroin and they
don't ever go back maybe that's the
altered state that you have to be in
it's a road human yeah yeah there it
goes well guys we to land the plane
right there on that runway uh stacey it
has been a delight to have you uh you
bring focus and perspective and expert
more and most importantly academic
expertise to what we do and that is
centered to the dna of star talk and of
course star talk sports edition gary
always good to have you man good job my
friend thank you both you guys and
this has been star talk sports edition
and the right hit what do we call this
gary the
this seemed to be the only thing you
could possibly call it that has football
players and smoking marijuana in the
same show all right we've got it neil
degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]